- NOT HAPPENING,
CHICKEN BANGER.
- OKAY, I'M JUST
GOING FOR THE BOOK, SO.
- YEAH, AROUND HERE,
AFTER 7:30,
IT'S ALICE IN CHAINS
OR NOTHIN'.
- OH, NOW, NOW.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME, BUD?
HEY, I'M BLAKE.
I'M A HARD ROCKER TOO,
SO I GET IT.
- AND I'M MARRIED,
BUTT PIRATE.
- HEY.
HANG ON, BUDDY.
WE'RE ALL FRIENDS, HERE.
NO NEED FOR THE NAME CALLING.
- [bleep] OFF, EDDIE BAUER!
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
- WHOA.
- I'VE GOT THIS.
YOU CAN'T TALK
TO MY FRIENDS THAT WAY.
- IS THAT A FACT?
- YEAH.
- I BET I CAN POUR
THIS BEER ON YOUR HEAD...
LIKE THAT.
- OH!
- HEY, COME ON, THAT'S A--
THAT'S A PERFECTLY GOOD MOLSON.
- HEY, [bleep]-HEAD!
TRY THAT AGAIN, AND THIS IS
GONNA HAPPEN TO YOUR DICK.
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S YOUR DING-DONG
IN TWO PIECES!
OH, I WANT YOU TO HIT ME
SO BAD RIGHT NOW!
JUST [bleep] HIT ME!
GET OUT OF HERE, YOU PUSSY!
- YES, MA'AM. HERE.
- YES, "YES, MA'AM."
NOW, GET OUT OF HERE...
PUSSY.
HERE YOU GO.
YOU WANT TO
SING SOMETHING, ADAM?
- [sobs] NO.
- NO.
- OH, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
- IT'S OKAY.
- ADAM, COME ON.
- I FEEL STUPID.
- NO, WE'RE GONNA GET--
WE'LL DRY YOU OFF.
- I KNOW, HE'S VERY DUMB.
- I FEEL STUPID!